venti minuti di episodio ebbene sì siamo
sua way out episodio 5 buona visione
ma dobbiamo rapinare questo posto
qualche est e infatti libera magona
tenga perché la vedo male allora la vedo
male anch'io però è tranquillo
tranquillo sa ripongono fiducia in the
life
come fai a riportato colore successo se
inizio la pistola e famiglie è infatti
non lo so come faccio per ora va bene
ciao ci servono i soldi tieni grazie
ciao
e così se funzionerà così sarà già
abbiamo sbagliato perché costi sparando
ho detto calma intanto di stoffa tende
al caramello
io divido palermo ristorante ciao
tecnica dei soldi ma io devo sarebbero
genere perché la zona dove saltare la
casa posso controllare sul retro aspetta
tutti enìa ora che manca di sparare
sembra kakà bravo ma gli ha controllato
signora che se la sta chiamando qualcuno
o chiocchio c'è un'arma c'è un'arma c'è
un'arma da caccia aveva un altro ok
faccio una cena cassaforte combinazione
fai a dire abbiamo ammirazione coyote
sbrigativo fecero quasi dai 137
ha funzionato ci sono dei soldi
beh non è così tanta roba scovava salve
comunque le sue caramelle sono
buonissime aiuto la palla auto l'auto
l'auto tanto questa vai vai vai alla
guida guida with hubble guida uomo guida
tory non voglio guidare di fare tutto
dunque adesso devo sparare io subito
vince provato una bruttissima ecco
allora un genio ma veggente un veggente
notre numero uno in inglese pure la lega
ha vinto tutti e le cose che si devono
di cogeme va bene dove ormai incazzato
me l'hai detto tu
[Risate]
lei fa trattamenti di armi sarà subito
la pelle teneva nel bagagliaio così va
bene posso scegliere me provo da va bene
questo baby non a me la bottiglia è
possibile provare in questo però è senza
la white
basta giocatore ha giocato giocato a
batterti minchia gli ebrei
andiamo andiamo possiamo andarcene cioè
stato bello grazie alle armi bella bene
con le dovevi quanto la zampa d'elefante
che belli pantaloni da tizia comunque
sigarettina lo dice a tanto sono a
piombino ma mi ha cambiato macchina mai
lei e lei questa a lei anche la tipa non
so non mi vuoi vedere che alleate con
quel pezzo d inverno sicuro ad un ciclo
di cure alla maledetta che bella casa
c'era vince di scialare a fare la
casetta e piccola ammazzar domarlo
dobbiamo arrivare fin lì fai te
intanto vincenti aspetto un bambino
questa è la moglie di chi si sente la
voglia mia o dio e mia moglie questa
l'ho messa incinta e siamo in messico
tra l'altro numeri di profecchia siamo
scappati lì apposta ma riconosco che mia
moglie l'ha riconosciuto caro al moretti
si va via va via in messico
vabbè al messico che arriviamo ma noi
stiamo andando esattamente dove sta
arrivi meno fingers when she loves e
amici
ecco però si è capito dove stiamo
andando a prendere un aereo che ho io
ma io devo chiamare io so io io sono il
contatto
ho trovato io cantavo io so chi chiamare
per l'aero pranzo ciccio è come se non è
un aereo da subito tra procure ecco
quale una bici in messico in bici ma
stai facendo cioè capisco leo perché
sono le cose faccio anche nella vita
reale che l'ha fatto ha trovato il
passaggio per il messico
credo non scherzavo
bene o che è successo a parte la sua
moglie no ma come se per suonarci tuo
figlio e cima del brann etico per
santana nitide più forte ma scusa ma
come io sono per produrre ottimi
no non è vero che facevano sapere che
eravamo qua poi fatti come il
silenziatore addirittura va bene quando
il miur a dire ok al tuo naso ci fa
scoprire che mira brutta mamma mi dice
il miglior nuovo c'è ma adora
incredibile alla mira più brutta del
secolo erano ferro eravamo fermi eravamo
fermi fiction rai dato core dittatore ci
becca mischiarsi sua mamma mia ma via
via via via via ti spingi spingi
preparano alla mala mala mala mala lì
però bastano pochi problemi a muoversi
mai nostro calcio devo fare troppo via
via via le ventole da che vado su aiuto
e laico di a spingere
era un secondo all'altro non troppo
sfonda lo dico io vieni vieni vieni
corri corri sta sfondando la ventola qua
ok altro il modo ci ha lasciati poi
shining mi segue e culo
ma no ma come ha fatto a vederci
impossibile percorso del naso e vedo il
mio è esatto
mentre allora spinge qua poi a dobbiamo
spingere no va bene vai ad essere destra
può o è un po deficiente potrebbe fare
il giro infatti scattino scattino
scattina scattino scattino scattava il
tendino imboscato vendita o bravo e
arrivo rivolto scuse li sta guardando la
scena arrivo sto guardando la scena
scusa mi ero divertito ero divertito
tutti
john cena siamo caduti tutti dei
deficienti 2 l'arma per l'arma siamo in
due dai li possiamo i servizi dei
mongoli di liferay bravo ma necessita e
foto di lorenzo t'ammazzo ammazzo ai
primariamente
per la cei è morto siamo stati proprio
bravi tu stai dicendo vedi tu noi dice
vito moglie ha un nuovo nome di pistola
dicevo che comunque si constata un
equipe signing eyes lytess ci spero
qui ci sarebbe il rospo
ok andiamo lescot ama 15 è la parte in
cui vanno mentana che si può così che
sono ricercati non è un po esatto ciao
siamo noi con i carcerati lì insieme per
quelli lì che cercano grazie mi dici
dove ma lo conosciamo 2 al solo
all'ultimo piano è vero ok
secondo quando va quando andrà a rotoli
della situazione ecco lo sapevo
oh ciao siamo noi cancellati no non ci
ha scoperti sono sarebbe un idiota che
[Musica]
si incamera di tua madre
ma sei scemo ma tu sei scemo ma poi se
ti vuoi un cazzo steam passo ti faccio
diventare il naso come il mio aspetto
tutti e due siamo d'accordo sulla ei bud
19 di questo mese lo riconosci blu
se ci avessero solo mettiamo console di
unire al problema e dove lo mettiamo
capito e poi ci sono profonde zio baby
ma che stai facendo qualcosa insieme
ma mia moglie sta partorendo io devo
stare in equilibrio su una sedia a
rotelle ma che problemi a certo a tutto
questo si sveglia la polizia che che sia
stato nell'ascensore sposami quindi la
polizia non è andata a cui stai facendo
per bocca ok stai correndo nella
cinematica
no no va va figuranti non mi sembrava
voglioso di venire non glielo chiedere
neanche non ci sarà mica la polizia
tenta cini imboscata fortissimo che
strano e per soci profilo cosa hai fatto
giovanna codato rodari
einstein è contenta di vedermi da o
fronte a righetti quindi lo passavo di
qua sto giocando le sedi a rotelle
pensato di essere trovate cismai do you
know how i meet a smorzare la fa a
cazzotti con qualcuno qua ed ha un
approccio ha avuto un figlio ci prova
dove godermi il momento per la smetti di
sbircerà di meno ma sei proprio una
stalker schifo cordata appunti
basta che stai facendo sotto la peggio
con la macchinetta io sto accusando mio
figlio tu sei per il mercato di una
macchinetta adesso dove è sempre appunti
sto gioco del q come culo il figlio che
romantici intanto ciccio dato tutto e
picchiandoli e se stessi e non ho ancora
finito con te macchinetta schifosa
guardali ed ecco vedi col gancio lo hai
visto gancio oh oh guarda non sapete
come posso dire lo sapevo ma forse
troppo scontata
io mi stupisco che non fossero già qua
c'è nel senso come fanno sapere ancora
come anno fa qualcuno ha chiamato sarà
mica che è il poliziotto sei svegliato
cosa vuol dire poi che cosa vuol dire
questa frase non sparato in un ospedale
marino esce magiche brutte cose mi sa
che io devo scappare dalla finestra
ciao tra le scale davvero
ciao ciao
sì è sì siamo nella cacca forte va bene
hai tu non ci sei sempre però ora chiama
htc aiuto corri corri corri attento
potrà sparare nomi possono stare che un
ospedale
eccoti la facciamo sempre prima troppo
io
esatto ad essere interessati mai cigs
life a vederli così capace è intenzione
breve mai sfondo lo becco cosa vuol dire
che non possono sparare perché siete in
un ospedale
questa non a quello che e picchiato
prima il cavolo di nuovo la presenza di
button e lui no non fare questa cosa se
lo avessi buttato giù io come ci sono
rinato lino fosse roccaraso è iniziata
da qualunque destra
salve buongiorno ho visto dottor house
stamattina era uguale a voi che va da
stampella maledizione come come come
facciamo di trovarci e gli stessi posti
per fatica porta illuminata vice sono si
aprisse una di soccorso
bravo così si fa ecco edificio di
nascondere ok ok perfetto vai vai vai
adesso adesso non perdete provato uscire
da quella portata lì esatto da questa
qua ha esitato riuscito lui
probabilmente lei sì sì bravo
ecco se non ti vedono sono orbi vai vai
vai entra in croce verde e vabbè è un
genio che avrebbe mai detto che curò
buttati giù giù nell'ascesa fatto che
ciao sono qui vorrei i continenti e
coincidenza scusa se te facendo ultimo
lavoro è bravi bravi per i più ricchi
come schiude salve
ok dove volevi andare su un ricordo
o se l'orario senza fare neanche un
checkpoint nicchia
ti piace il mio culetto specie se
nell'altra ventola caso plana 6 nella
cosa dell'ascensore
ok ma funziona davvero sta cosa di
metterla sedia lì è diventato un gioco
il budino street fighter cosa vedo una
fatality guardali nov al nostro gioco
geniale e bellissimo no no no no non
rompere non rompere la catena non siamo
morti anche tra quello che accade non
rompere la catena o bellissimo è
diventato in 2d ma è un gioco fantastico
questo bellissimo e vabbè trauma cranico
bari tel como o merda mai tech fuori è
la vecchia occhio
io sono qui 2 contro mille metal gear
dalle ventole posso uscire
magari un ottimo cammino ancora dentro
cosa trovo alla finestra a finestra
ciao persone buttarmi giù dalla finestra
brava
controlliamo le finestre per ischia
mamma mamma
bene bene bene
ma c'è una scala qua fatto apposta per
chi vuole fuggire grazie al posto sicuro
fugge infatti la porta da buttarsi gara
per i ladri ma hanno le gambe di ferro
ai ragazzi un fatto domanda intanto 100
c sotto di vedere il fatto dalla
strategia ancora o ancora che meghni
gente è qua non
no non mi sparate non sparate di sparare
non uccidere nessuno come la casa di
carta non devi fare vittime in final
four a una buona con col fido davvero se
ti e piaciuto inizio un sacco ci siamo
dati delle opinioni e vederli perfetto
questi giusti professionali e tre tra
entra entra è prima ancora di ccteu r
c'è una solenne da dove stai a nord
sotto il naso
l'ultima battuta è quello che 30
io sono io sono andato tranquillamente a
piedi si è fatta
ciao a posto grazie come c'è arrivato la
lista c'era una polizia
sto aspettando che qualcosa tra tata che
bello spirito nella società trombacca
che con bavera posso andare via ok ciao
lo sono io giuro che dovevo andare di
qua è così perfetto di opposto
3 stiamo andando esattamente scavalca
figurati giù dalla finestra aggiunge
giorgio gesù io ne sono uscita rompere 3
vetri
il francesino culo tu sei lì ancora ok
siamo usciti nello stesso luogo e poi
aprire i giorni a venire bene niente
niente niente
no non ci credo
o no come fai liberarvi devo essere io
sia per forza come faccio aiutarti che
non so mai dove vai
cosa devo fare con l'auto dei fucili ai
giorno in ciò e l'hiv aids dell'iss
maledizione sono un po stronzo non so
che non dovrei concludere qua però sono
stronzo è però nel prossimo episodio che
sarà il penultimo succederà ancora di
peggio di ragazzi se proprio vi sia
piaciuto come mi piace rischiare sono
stato lì si chiede e noi ci vediamo
subito bene grazie
[Musica]